most men avoid therapy because most
therapy approaches are not designed to
help the male brain deal with pain or
find solutions that makes men believe
therapy is worthless male depression is
usually based on feeling helpless
powerless and unable to affect one's
life or environment therapy models focus
on helping men feel heard and loved
instead of restoring their sense of
personal power men need Solutions not
just feelings absolutely and we are
churning out here in the United States
an overwhelming number of therapists who
do not have the skills that they need or
the experience that they need to provide
lasting solutions that will undiagnose
you in the long term when you get a man
into that system men would rather kill
themselves than sit there and say I am
disabled I must have medical assistance
for the rest of my life and all I can do
is sit here and talk about my feelings
endlessly for the next 10 years while
paying ten thousand dollars for the
privilege men are looking for Solutions
and they're looking for guidance in how
to apply those Solutions when you give
them those things men will do just about
anything for you